hello everybody it is September 2nd 2017
so it's time for another monthly update
video from my viewers subscriber as
other fans where I'm going to talk about
what went on in August and what we've
got coming up in September I always like
to begin by highlighting three big
things that I want to bring your
attention to so without any further ado
here they are big thing number one we
are now at the 200 video mark for half
our hagel that series that I've been
doing for really three and a half years
so we're gonna have a Hegel Party online
everybody's invited more about that in
the September portion second thing we
are going to continue with our
philosophy pop-up series patreon
supporters find out about this in
advance everybody else finds out the day
of that's why it's a pop-up and this
month we're going to be talking about
stoicism and in particular what in
accordance with nature means since
that's a topic that a lot of people
express some confusion about third big
thing is in the last two weeks I got
hired by Marquette University to put
together and teach to ethics courses so
that's that's kind of big news I'll talk
about that more in the August part so
what took place in the month of August
well we had a few online and a few
face-to-face events I got to speak about
HP Lovecraft somebody who I have been
reading really since middle school and
and I very much enjoy so that was in the
worlds of speculative fiction series
hosted here in the Milwaukee area we
also had another talk in a different
series the philosophers in the midst of
history and I talked about Thomas Hobbes
the English Civil War and the you know
rise of modern political theory and
Hobbes is role in that so that was
pretty cool as well and then we did our
monthly webinars and seminars were back
on track with though
this time around we we tackled jean-paul
sartre and his conceptions of human
responsibility and freedom if you want
to see the video for any of those you
can look at the description below and
you will find links to them I did a lot
of tutoring and a good bit of
philosophical counseling and some
consulting over the month of August I
actually picked up several new clients
who want regular meetings by the way if
you're interested in that sort of thing
check out my website reason IO dot-com
or you can email me directly if you're
looking for somebody who tutors
everybody from CEOs and other professors
down to regular students and lifelong
learners I've got you know some some
good sessions for you if you're into
that sort of thing the other really big
news of course that I mentioned in the
three big things is that I got hired
rather last minute by Marquette
University to teach suit two sections of
ethics they had opened up now this is a
class that I have been teaching for
about 20 years so as you know part of
the reason why they call me up is they
they knew that I could sort of hit the
ground running with it and so that
involved as usual a lot of in processing
you know there's a lot of paperwork to
fill out there's a lot of you know
waiting for the paperwork to get to this
point and then go to that point and and
you know I am now set up with with all
of the accoutrements that a professor
needs an office access to the online you
know websites for courses thing which
they call d2l an email address you know
all those those sorts I do know how
those those sorts of things and
everybody's been very nice and and I've
had a great time and it's just right
down the road from from where I live and
work so it's really convenient for me
and I had my first two classes enjoyed
you know the conversations with the
students who seem like a pretty
motivated bunch to learn and so I'm
really having a great time with it
another big thing is we are in the
modern stoicism organization getting
ready for stoical on up in Toronto and
stoical week so a lot of behind the
scenes stuff going on a lot of hours put
in on that more than than usual on
stoicism today you know I edit that and
so we've been we've been commissioning a
lot of pieces and I've been doing it
that of writing as well the other big
thing that I did in the month of August
was I although this was recorded earlier
in July my my interview with the death
hangout people Olivia and Keith came out
talking about stoic attitudes towards
death and how to live a more full and
productive life I did shoot some some
videos didn't get to quite as much as I
had hoped in part because the the sudden
you know working for Marquette thing has
understandably taken a lot of my time
I got through my quota of half hour
Haegele videos for the month I hosted a
Heidegger pop up both in YouTube the
YouTube live video and also in Facebook
and I shot core concept videos finishing
up on Heidegger and then shooting some
on Hegel and specifically on the
master-slave dialectic so if you're
interested in that sort of thing you
want to go to the video channel the
other thing that I should mention that I
was doing was some course building still
working on those teachable courses and
the reason I Oh Academy
but once Marquette hired me that had to
take sort of a little backseat to
getting the courses for Marquette ready
to roll and and online so what is going
on in the month of September a lot yeah
very very busy month so let me talk
about events first
and let me start by talking about
philosophy pop-ups so like I mentioned
in the three big things
these are you know roughly 30 minutes of
one-hour sessions that are hosted on
Facebook live or on YouTube live and the
only people who know about them well in
advance are the people who are my
patreon supporters so good incentive to
become a patreon supporter if you're not
already otherwise you can find out
through social media the day of the
event I will post hate I'm going to be
having a a pop up so it could happen any
time during the month you just got to
stay tuned to social media and it's a
great way to ask me questions we're
gonna be talking this month specifically
about stoicism and about the Stoics
understanding of nature and what being
in accordance with nature means for the
Stoics this is a topic that I think
there's a lot of confusion and
controversy about but people can ask me
about other things as well because they
do and then we have a lot of scheduled
events well actually the puppets are
already scheduled but again patreon
supporters know about that in advance so
Sunday the 10th of September from 2:00
to 3:00 p.m. I'm going to be having a
hagel party everybody's invited it's
online you can lift a glass of whatever
it is that you like to drink you know
wine beer hard liquor
kerosene tea coffee whatever I'll be
having a beer or two and we'll talk
about the half hour Hagel project and
the fact that we've gotten to 200 videos
and we'll maybe talk about Hagel as well
or dialectical philosophy or whatever
else people want to talk about but it's
essentially a big celebration and again
everybody is invited you don't have to
be a member of the half hour Hagel
Project supporter group or anything like
that you don't even necessarily need to
know that much about Hagel just just
show up and we'll have a good time
Monday the 11th we will be having our
free webinar on Plato's symposium
talking about love sex and politics
that's a 45-minute session at 11 o'clock
P 11:00 o'clock a.m. Central Time of
Cour
Thursday the 14th here in Milwaukee at
the Brookfield public library we'll be
having our monthly worlds of speculative
fiction series session and this time
we're going to be talking about William
Gibson's sprawl trilogy starting with
you know Neuromancer going through count
zero and Mona Lisa overdrive so it's
gonna be a really fun session thinking
about you know cyberspace and all of
that Saturday the 16th at 10 o'clock
a.m. and 4:00 o'clock p.m. that is when
we're gonna be having our to our
intensive seminars on Plato's symposium
going much deeper into into the the text
and talking again about that topic love
sex and and politics how are these
things connected in Plato's symposium so
that's going to be a great experience
those are available online and I will
try to put a link to that fairly fairly
soon as well Tuesday the 19th we will be
having from 5:00 to 6:00 the our normal
monthly Hegel Q&A which is underwritten
by the supporters of the half-hour Hegel
project that's the other patreon that I
have so if you you know think that
studying Hegel is something worthwhile
you want to contribute then you may want
to become a supporter you don't have to
be a supporter in order to go to that of
course because it's a public Q&A I have
another one for my patreon supporters
Thursday the 21st also here locally 6
o'clock p.m. at the Shorewood Public
Library in in the women you should read
series I'm going to be talking about
somebody who I think many of you know I
have a keen interest in Mary
Wollstonecraft I'm going to be talking
more this time
some of her other works besides just the
vindication of the rights of women in
part because I've done a lot of talking
about that recently but now I'd like to
talk a bit more about her novels and her
travel writings and then finally
Thursday the 28th from 6:00 to 7:00 also
at the Shorewood Public Library
graciously hosting this stoic fellowship
the MKE stoic fellowship we will be
meeting and I've put a pull for those
who are involved in that about what
we're going to be studying next as we
gear up for stoical on and stoical week
happening in october I mentioned that
you know I'm teaching at Marquette now
so I'm on campus two days a week
sometimes actually three days a week if
I decide I want to go into the office on
Wednesdays and so I'm going to be doing
a lot of work building out those courses
in d2l taking the stuff that I developed
you know earlier in other systems and
putting it into their d2l course
learning environment to build an entire
online course learning module for my
students so I'm looking forward to that
this this month we're gonna be talking
about Alistair McIntyre mine Rand
Epicurus Jeremy Bentham and John Stuart
Mill I don't think we're gonna get to
Cicero we're reading the on duties a
little bit later what else I'm you know
still doing a lot of tutoring
I've got philosophical counseling
clients still doing some consulting as a
matter of fact that's actually gearing
up as we move into some really cool
phases on the projects I'm working on
doing a lot of writing some of which you
will see a peer this month some of which
is for longer term book projects I will
say that I have won one book project
actually going later this fall to the
two as a prospectus to the Frankfurt
Book Fair so I'm very excited about that
doing some more podcast interviews this
month as a matter of fact you'll see two
in
come out definitely this month one with
philosophy bakes bread and then the
other with Tom Ritchie's podcast
discussing various topics what else
we've got a lot of video work this month
I am going to of course get my normal
six half hour Haegele videos done we're
in a cool section of the work right now
core concept videos I'm planning on
shooting core concept videos on
Nietzsche's truth and lying in an extra
moral sense which is really fun short
piece but I'm also creating new core
concept videos for my Marquette students
because I thought about it I probably
could use a few more on some of these
authors so Alistair McIntyre is plain
persons and moral moral philosophy I'm
shooting some stuff on that shooting
some stuff on Iran's virtue of
selfishness shooting some stuff a little
bit of stuff on Epicurus gonna shoot a
bit more stuff on Jeremy Bentham and his
introduction to the principles of morals
and legislation and then finally when I
was going through the videos I realized
I could use some more work on John
Stuart Mill and utilitarianism so I'm
gonna be cranking that stuff out then if
I can get to the Cicero I need to do
shoot some stuff on Cicero's on duties
and hopefully I'll be able to get to
that and then I think for the rest of
the semester I'm pretty well covered
I've got a lot of Ross and Kant
Aristotle I could probably shoot some
more Thomas Aquinas oh and I need to
shoot some stuff on Wollstonecraft too
because I built her into the course so a
lot of core concept videos I'm also
shooting some videos for my Marquette
students that I think may be of interest
to other students in other places so for
example I'm the first one I'm going to
shoot is kind of a pep talk telling my
students that they really are capable of
engaging with primary texts and reading
them and getting something out of them
I'm a if I get to it redo the how to
read a philosophical text video that I
did years and years back you know I want
to shoot some other videos I'm just you
know what is plagiarism and how to avoid
it all those sorts of things that I
think students may find very useful I
was able to shoot one Sadler's soapbox
video last month I'd intended to shoot a
few more and I do have a few things I
want to talk about on the soapbox so I
will be shooting several more of those
this month I also want to start the book
reviews and I'm starting a series called
Sadler's honest reviews people have been
sending me books to do reviews on and
it's about time I actually got to that
and then I want to do a few personal
videos as well since people have been
asking about those sorts of things so
gonna be a very very busy month but I'm
very excited about all the events and
the classes and the video work and all
the things that we've got going got a
lot of good momentum heading into the
fall and then you know October is gonna
be super super busy because we have
stoical on stoical week I'll be doing a
few talks here and there for stoical
week including down in Chicago as well
speaking out it's stoic on so I'm
gearing up for all of that as well so
hope that you have a great month ahead
and I hope to see you as well in some of
these online events or if you're in the
area pop in and say hello as we go
through you know some of these these
things like William Gibson and Mary
Wollstonecraft
you